joining me now is our defense and
security analyst Professor Michael
Clarke hello there to you Michael and
that address there the unscheduled
National address is unequivocally
a Russian president who's trying to tell
the people I'm in control
yes and what was interesting Sam is just
how angry he appeared normally when you
see President Putin he makes these
statements and he makes them with a sort
of a rather passive face you can see
there he was really angry and he uses uh
very clear language he says this is
treason this is an armed Mutiny it's all
part of the the the the the problem that
Russia is having to defend itself
against whatever these forces are that
he says are trying to destroy it so that
the speech itself you know unexpected
quite brief but angry and you can tell
here that Putin must know that his whole
special military operation is not just
on the line but his power is now on the
line I mean I suspect he will emerge
from this weakened but I I bet he will
emerge from it I'm just guessing
um but nevertheless this is far and away
his biggest crisis in 23 years and it's
blown up in about 36 hours in reality
make of
um precautions Ambitions to march on
Moscow he's got putative 25
000 troops why does he think that that's
realistic well it's not realistic I mean
25 000 troops I mean they may be
fighting in the verones which seems to
be the case there's something going on
there I mean that's still 300 miles from
Moscow and 25 000 troops are not going
to march on Moscow as such but what
progotten is is banking on I'm pretty
sure is that the army or significant
units in the Army will sit on their
hands you know whenever we're dealing
with coups or attempted coups the armies
that sit on their hands are just as
important as the armies who turn out and
fight and because in when you look at
his his astonishing statements that he
made on on Thursday night Friday morning
and this this little clip that you're
running now is where he's talking to uh
yevkarov who's the deputy defense
minister and he's very rude to him
looking really very awkward and he's
speaking there for ordinary people
because he said at this meeting you can
see it you know he's speaking to the two
of them and he makes it making it very
clear he said we have come to end the
disgrace to the country in which we live
that's what we are doing and he says
you're wasting troops you're throwing
them in senseless useless attacks and
that sort of language of course is
exactly what a lot of the troops on the
front know to be the case so pragodian
isn't just talking about his Wagner
forces here he's making a play I'm
pretty sure for the Loyalty of
significant units of the regular forces
and if they're not going to turn out and
fight for him he wants them to sit on
their hands as the next phase of this
crisis unwinds and I bet that's that's
what he himself is actually well I think
we'll hear more from him soon and I
think that's what his next Ploy will be